two men are due in court in washington
later today accused of impersonating
federal agents and then using financial
favors to get close to the first lady's
security detail more than a dozen fbi
agents raided an apartment in the
nation's capitol yesterday court
documents allege that the suspects
pretended to be
department of homeland security
employees and then paid for pricey
apartments for secret service officials
ed o'keefe is in washington with more on
the story ed not quite sure exactly what
this is but we sure know the optics are
not good for the secret service that is
right gail good morning good to see you
according to the affidavit ariane
taherzadeh and haider ali created a
sophisticated scheme to integrate
themselves with federal law enforcement
court documents show they obtained
police equipment guns and other items
used by federal officers taherzadeh sent
photos of himself and tactical gear to
one secret service agent another photo
shows him with police equipment and a
closet they went as far as using stock
photos to pretend they were in a
training class for homeland security the
two men lived at this d.c apartment
building and falsely told residents they
were federal agents even gaining access
to the building's surveillance cameras
the pair allegedly gave lavish gifts and
paid the rent of some secret service
agents one of them assigned to protect
first lady jill biden and allegedly was
offered a two thousand dollar assault
rifle by tahersaday the plot started
unraveling when a u.s postal inspector
interviewed the two men as potential
witnesses to an unrelated crime just
last month the suspects claimed they
were quote special police and when their
stories didn't match up the fbi was
called in the secret service says all
its personnel involved are on
administrative leave pending an
investigation
so ed let's think about this for a
second we're talking about secret
service agents that had access to the
first lady and then potentially the
president who took gifts and rent money
what else is the secret service saying
about all of this yeah you're right
court documents say more than 40 000 in
rent was paid to at least two agents the
secret service says those involved are
now restricted from accessing agency
facilities equipment and systems but
there's no word on whether further
disciplinary action may be taken
investigators haven't revealed the
motive but according to residents of
that apartment building the pair had
been pretending to be federal law
enforcement for the past couple of
months and what their endgame exactly is
remains unclear hopefully we'll learn
more later this morning
yes yes yes you're on the case more to
come thank you ed